My name is Kwon Dae-hyeon.
I am currently running a game company called
'Zabob Studio'.
Our company has only two members, my wife
and myself.
I founded this company when I married my wife
and resigned from my previous company in November
2013.
We have made about ten games so far.
Among them, our representative games are "ZOMBIE
JUDGEMENT DAY" and "INFINITY DUNGEON".
When we launched it, as a startup company
that cannot spend a lot of budget on marketing,
we experienced a lot of stress about how we're
going to promote it.
I guess every developer faces this problem.
We tried to find ways to market our games
efficiently, at a lower cost.
Great ideas are our competitive edge because
we cannot afford to develop or compete with
large-scale games.
We tried painstakingly hard to figure out
what type of games would help us win this
competition based on this idea.
Fortunately, our game was selected as the
"Play Picks"
which helped us to promote our game to global
users.
After the support from Google, we recorded
about 400,000 downloads for about two months,
and
our sales revenue reached about 140 million
won.
Of course, South Korea was the country that
loved our game the most.
But downloads and sales revenue from the other
regions, including the United States, also
represented about 60%.
One of the advantages of developing Android
games is the Google Play Game Service.
This service enables developers to easily
access ready-to-use features required for
games, including ranking, achievements and
quests,
and of course we have benefited a lot from
the service.
You can also find a variety of statistics
in Google Play's developer console.
The best part is that developers can communicate
with their users directly by replying to their
reviews,
and this definitely differentiates the console
from others.
The success of "ZOMEBIE JUDGEMENT DAY" and
"INFINITY DUNGEON" on the Google Play Store
gave us some much-needed funds.
So we are satisfied that we can develop games
in a more affordable environment now.
I think that while it is important to ensure
the completeness of a game,
it is more advantageous to release a game
early when it reaches a certain degree of
completion
and receive feedback from users and update
it, continuing to improve its service.
We want Zabob Studio to become a "couple-run"
global game developer by pursuing this strategy.